[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice dr
john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we talk about your relationships your
boundaries your mental health your job
your career and your money it's what we
do every day on the ramsey show thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
andrew's with us in la
california los angeles hi andrew how are
you
i'm doing awesome how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so um my wife and i were going over our
tax information and we were having a
slight disagreement um but we not
necessarily on the details just on like
the general
way in which we're looking at things i'm
wanting to max out my step ira i am a
freelancer i've been maxing out my step
ira
pretty much since i got it
and she feels like we have more than
enough saved in retirement and
she doesn't see why we would keep
putting
so much money in a lock box that has a
do not open until 60 lock on it
okay
well if it's going it should be a roth
ira to start with um not a traditional
um
yeah well i have we have two roth iras
she has one and i have one we maxed that
out and then i have my step ira which is
i don't think there is a roth option for
the stuff ira yeah that's what i would
certainly believe yes there is yeah so
you can't you can do a role there is
yeah
okay now how much are you putting in the
sale i guess
um
this year would be around 40 000 and
then we're also doing the
six thousand into the each of the roster
52 000 that would be we would be putting
in what's your household uh investments
a year um
it changes year to year um
somewhere in the 150 to 200 thousand
drinks is take home
you're going to have is your home paid
for
yes so you're 100 debt free
yes
okay um
how old are you
33.
what are the balances of the of these
accounts currently
let's see the sep ira um i haven't
looked at it like recently because they
just took a nasty hit but it's somewhere
around 385
and then about 100 in my roth iras and
then about
53 in her roth ira and then we have a
couple 401ks that we have yet to convert
to iras for complicated reasons and
those have about
uh 40 between the two of those
okay
well
you're right it's a philosophical
argument more than anything else the
only reason that i would agree with her
would be
if you want to do some investing outside
of these because you've got enough going
in to create what we would call bridge
accounts to bridge between now and 59
and a half if you wanted to access some
of the wealth before 59 and a half
because you get 600 000 and 33 years old
if you keep that in good growth stock
mutual funds you're going to be in
really really good shape in those
accounts without adding anything to it
so um
but
i i'm always of the opinion if i can
keep the government's hands off the
money i'm going to keep their hands off
of it if you have zero other investments
though um she probably has a bit of a
point
does she want to invest the money or
spend it
does she want to buy real estate go buy
a rental house or something or does she
want to get cooler cars
i
probably more the former i don't think
that there's a specific idea of what she
wants to do with it it's just a matter
of
when we look on like the ramsey
investment calculator how we're going to
have tens of millions of dollars by the
time we retire anyway she's like what
okay what why why are we building this
up even more we're already like well the
reason you're building up more is your
the reason you're building up more
building wealth and all the things that
you can do with wealth which is
generosity and change your family tree
and all those kinds of things the only
point that i would agree with her on is
not not is it you know can you save too
much no you can't save too much i mean
unless you don't have a life you need to
have a life in there in in your budget
uh but uh you don't have a payment in
the world you've done very very well at
33 years old living in los angeles i
mean my gosh well you're killing it
so
the only reason she would have a point
would be if you wanted to access some of
the wealth prior to 59 and a half for
something
to do something with um in our case i'll
give you an example we had
a thousand years ago it feels like we
had a had saved up a hundred and fifty
thousand bucks in a non-uh
retirement
uh
mutual fund and uh and i found a little
lake house a very little lake house
that uh on a really nice lot and it was
the first thing we ever bought
that wasn't like our home survived it
was it like the first
toy thing luxury thing we bought we
bought a lake house but it was like a
it's like a thousand square foot brick
1974 you know it was it wasn't like a
palace or anything but
it was an estate we got a deal on it at
the time and it was the year 2000
uh so it's 22 years ago you know and and
i bought it for 103 000
and i took some of that money and did
that now that's long before obviously i
was 59 and a half so it was good that i
had that
money other wealth to be able to do
something like that and and that's
probably the stage that you're heading
towards can somebody who's done as well
as he had i never thought about this
until just now
can you
play this the retirement game so well
that you make it yourself completely
you lack liquidity so much you almost
trap yourself because if he has a couple
of down years he may have a million
dollars in these retirement accounts but
no other yeah no money you're not you're
not trapped but that's the point i mean
you're gonna
she's on to something
is what you're saying and i'm saying i'm
just wondering yeah yeah that that's uh
that you could go ahead and start doing
some other just um mutual fund investing
something like a low turnover mutual
fund maybe just an s p 500 which is what
i pulled that lake house money out of
and you build that money up and then you
say okay we're going to do something
else with that investment wise or we're
going to do something else with that
consumption or generosity wise does that
does that s p
mutual fund earned less return than
these retirement accounts no but it's
taxable
okay and the roth ira is whatever mutual
fund is not taxable right okay so that's
the difference and
it is if you leave alone a year it's
taxable
at a capital gains rate a lower rate but
you know it's a way to park some money
that you can get to without any
penalties
and uh with limited taxation gotcha uh
until you until
as a bridge to get between now and 59
and a half to be able to access some of
it so yeah you're probably
needing to do some of that at this stage
you've done so well congratulations that
was a beautiful beautiful thing you
pulled off very very fun man that is fun
man yeah it's
and what a great discussion
i mean we're on baby step seven house is
paid for we live in l.a we make 150 a
year my wife and i are sitting and
looking at stuff
and the only argument we've got is how
we do investing
[Laughter]
these are not things that people deal
with very often unless they've been very
very intentional
and uh really really good stuff
congratulations well done well done
dr john dolone ramsey personality my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
half of americans over 65 will need
long-term care
average cost is now 138 000 you got a
plan for your long-term care needs
especially by the time you're 60 years
old i don't recommend long-term care
insurance until you're 60 but after that
i do
medicare will not pay for everything and
medicaid
nursing home is welfare
so you don't qualify for government
nursing home unless you're on welfare so
we recommend long-term care insurance
for people aged 60 and over it helps pay
for nursing home care assisted living
even in home care
and that way you get to keep your
independence and your savings long-term
care insurance protects your family too
because your spouse your kids won't have
to bear the financial and emotional
burden of caring for you guys here's how
it works seventy-five percent of you
ladies outlive your husbands
and the typical scenario negative
scenario is 300k in the retirement
account
and papa goes into the nursing home
cracks and scrambles the nest egg uses
it for the nursing home dies leaves mama
home broke
used up the nest egg
get long-term care insurance our network
of endorsed local providers will help
you understand your long-term care
insurance options and find the right
policy for
you
visit ramseysolutions.com
long-term care and we'll help you get
started ramsey solutions.com
long-term care and we'll hook you up
with an elp we'll get this going
clayton's with us clayton is in portland
oregon hi clayton how can dr john and i
help
hi you guys it's nice to speak with you
you too
um i saw you in yours in the smart
conference at sacramento my wife and i
went down before the pandemic and so
it's really fun to be able to see that
and be a part of that well thank you
we're doing another one finally in
dallas in the fall october 22nd maybe
you can come down for it yeah we'd love
to
so i do have a question um i have grown
siblings my wife and i are doing pretty
well we're on baby step six
and uh our annual combined salary is
around 200 000.
um we have
close to six hundred thousand therefore
we both have opinions you know we're
doing really well so we only 155 on our
house and it's worth over 400. wow
so the question that i have is with my
siblings
my sister and i were adopted when we
were little
my mom proceeded to have two more
siblings
after we were adopted out
and we recently got in contact with them
about four years ago so we're all in our
50s
now and
the trauma from
being in an alcoholic home has really
caused a lot of damage over the years
the three other siblings don't really
have a whole lot going on financially or
otherwise
but
the problem for my wife and i is because
we're doing so well
we feel bad
when we can't help them or we don't help
them
you know with finances or anything like
that and we feel like we're doing wrong
when we do because we feel like we're
enabling
the situation so i guess we just need
some guidance on
how to deal with that situation
that's hard man i'm so sorry
well
um that's the beginning of our story i
mean we haven't finished yet our story's
still going so yeah i mean i she was
pretty rough i mean she did they did
they call you
do they i mean do they call you hit you
up for money how does that interaction
work um it's small stuff it's usually i
can't meet this i can't meet the
expenses like um one of my brothers
couldn't pay for his rent and then
another one when we went to see
our brother he
didn't have enough money to get back
home
and then my sister i've been helping her
for years with money because she's just
now she's disabled
and she gets a disability check but she
just doesn't have she isn't able to make
ends meet you know so
it's a really tough situation for us you
know i get up at 4am and go to work
every day i have i'm 30 years at the
same job and so
we earn that money and we feel like
we're doing the right thing but we just
need to know
where to put or what to do with all that
so
we're kind of at a loss
as far as
is it okay to help them or
are we enabling that behavior do we you
know i don't i don't know them well
enough to just speak on
their lives yeah except this
when somebody invites themselves into
your life to ask you for your resources
that is permission as far as i'm
concerned
to then
speak on the utilization of that money
right how is this money helping or
hurting somebody yeah if if you have the
guts to ask me for money i have the guts
to tell you how to use it because it's
mine right
and the idea that you're a bank account
or a blank check for other people that's
completely dysfunctional that's right
that's right that's just guilty well
there's no doubt that dysfunction's
there we're all native american and
in the native american community it's
it's a different it's kind of a
different dynamic because we really give
i mean we try to absolutely my heart is
a giving heart you know and i feel bad
you know when i don't so here's the
thing
here's the thing you use the word help
and when you're giving you should
help so you need to define
help
differently
help is not giving a drunk a drink
that's enabling that's not help
help is not participating in funding
someone's delusions or craziness or
misbehavior that's not help
so if when you give them money if as a
result of you giving them money
they're not better
then you didn't help
you made yourself feel better for a few
days and you made them feel better for a
few days and now they go back to the
exact same behavior
that's not a native american thing
that's an enabling thing
in any culture
so you're not
helping
when you give a drunk a drink
and that's the classic line about
enabling you're not helping enabling
when i'm when i'm an enabler and i'm not
very often but i have been at times
i get caught in some kind of crossfire
some kind of triangulation or something
and i feel
like i'm caught and i've got to do this
and i feel trapped and it's
it's all a false premise but i get
myself in there just like everybody else
does
and and i feel like i'm helping but
they're not better when i'm done
then i that they didn't move along to a
better life you know then i didn't
really help
it's kind of like telling people what
they want to hear
just so they'll feel okay and yet that
didn't really help them instead we have
to tell them the truth on this show
and sometimes
you're so harsh you know i just love you
enough to tell you the truth because i
want you to be better after our
conversation which would be better after
i give you this check and so if i'm
giving money to your brother for rent
and to my brother for rent if i'm you
it's going to sound like okay
here's what this comes with
okay we're all trying to survive this
train wreck of a family
and we're all trying to get better and
i'm willing to help you with your rent
if you get better and that means you're
going to get on a budget and you're
going to send me a copy of the budget
before i send you the money
and you're going to promise me that
you're going to read this total money
makeover book or you're going to go to
this financial peace university class
i'll pay for it
but you've got to go you've got to get
better i'm going to use the money as
leverage in their life to lift them
not to participate in their stuff and
let's be honest the response is going to
be who do you think you are oh mr fancy
and you're going to say i'm your brother
and i love you exactly
you don't owe an explanation for who i
think i am is i think i'm the guy with
the money over here that cares about you
and i love you that's right
i care about you and so i'm gonna dangle
this money right in front of your
freaking nose to help you can i tell you
this to be prepared for clayton
one or two of them of your siblings
won't take it and you will be the bad
guy
for trying to make long-term help
okay prepare your heart for that and
that doesn't mean that you failed that
means that they are still struggling
right yeah
um yeah that's understood yeah when you
won't participate in their deal then
they go there
and so you know the thing is this um
the version of you that they create
in their head
is not your responsibility
if they want to make you into the
villain
and they say you you can't control
somebody making you into a villain when
you're doing the right thing that's
going to happen sometimes you do the
right thing and people call you villain
that's right and they they write a
narrative in their own brain that you're
a villain and they don't get a vote and
you know you just don't understand
you're not like a real part of our
family
you know and
you uh you didn't got uppity hadn't you
you know and all this stuff and yeah uh
yeah whatever that's exactly what
happened i guess but what really
happened is i love you so much i ain't
participating in crazy no more bud
that's what we're doing some true help
yeah and that's not tough love that's
real love
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author the brand new book
on pre-sale own your past
change your future a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness this book is
absolutely stunning and amazing
if you have not bought your pre-order
copy yet the actual shipping oak
happened
in early april when we actually the book
actually launches but we're on pre-sale
right now if you haven't bought your
copy you should you get a month of
counseling with the folks that better
help and you get the audio book and the
e-book and
you know the the total package is worth
hundreds of dollars so you really need
to check this out all for a 20 book you
don't want to miss that at all so own
your past change your future at
ramseysolutions.com
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jason and ashley are
with us hey guys how are you hey dave
welcome welcome where do you guys live
uh goose creek south carolina right
outside charleston oh yeah beautiful
area well welcome it's good to have you
guys good to see you and uh how much
debt have you paid off almost 77 000 of
soul-crushing debt oh right
that's a particular type of that john
soul crushing yeah and so
how long did this take about 26 months
we started in september 2019 ended uh
november 2019 2021 oh sorry very good
very good and your range of income
during that two years um it went from
forty six thousand dollars to a hundred
and three thousand dollars wow what do
y'all do for a living um she is a
payroll specialist for a local
municipality and i am a vehicle
appraiser for a very progressive uh
insurance company um
see what he did there
very good i was an honor student i got
that when he slipped that right through
there so how did you double your income
um well whenever we first started out um
well i could go back a little bit i
first started listening to you in uh
2010 and um we really didn't do anything
about it i just run home and tell her i
heard this crazy guy on the radio and he
was talking about all this and i get
excited but i never really led my family
and said let's
let's do this you know
fast forward a few years i get into a
really bad accident at work
led me to have to leave my job
and spent three years without a job
where this beautiful lady supported me
while i took care of the kids at home
and
i started to kind of get to that feeling
where i thought maybe they wouldn't be
or they
might be better off without me
um but i battled through that got a
bunch of insurance certifications
um battled my way into my job and uh
then my wife told me that she was
wanting to leave her job and it it
really worried me i wasn't that
supportive of a husband
i spent 14 years in a
retail pharmacy and oh
yes that would take your soul like that
debt will won't
it was so crushing so i just got to a
point where i was in a place where i was
like i can't do this anymore
and i just looked at him and said i'm
leaving yeah i'm done
so um i will come up with a plan but
right now i'm done yeah
so that's who was who was making the 46
when you started this he was he was okay
so you were out but then you got a new
job yeah and that's how it doubled you
got it okay the amazing thing was
whenever we got into the class she
actually came to me and said they're
offering fpu at church um
you know if you'd want to go and i
actually resisted even though i've been
listening to you for a while because i
thought that's a hundred dollars that we
desperately need right now
we went into the class let's go out to
eat 100 and talk about
it but um but we got into the class and
we just we just devoted ourselves we we
submitted to the plan
and the the the blessings just it's like
god opened up the heavens and just said
i see what you're doing you're trying
here you go because within three weeks
she got a uh her current job
well i was at least interviewed for the
current job it was within a couple of
months that way that i was actually
full-on what church
um it's uh st james united methodist
church great okay
so she got her new job and i actually
got a new position in my company that
raised my salary and of course she was
working again so all that totaled right
about the time you start financial peace
university
that's why i say it just so that's what
kicked this off 26 months ago was the
class really yeah and then the job comes
in and puts fire on the gas on the fire
okay 100 yeah very good cool so what
kind of debt was the 77 000 well we had
cell phones we had credit cards we had a
car loan um and but most of this was uh
sally mae hmm yeah had to give the old
woman her eviction notice you better
believe it kicked her butt out there you
go i love it how long you been out of
college
uh she's uh 2005 for may 2003 for him
yeah okay so uh 15 years
she's been hanging around time for her
to go oh yeah yeah good so tell me about
the the little wins and whenever
someone's struggling with
just being down in a hole like you were
it's these little tiny steps and
somebody believing in you
tell me about that
well
the little ones were probably the easier
way to do it just to start and we'd be
like all right we paid that off we never
thought we'd pay that off okay we got
that paid off
and then we'd work up to it it really
felt like as we worked up to it like the
last one was
he had larger student debts than i did
because
i made him go to my private
methodist college that my family had all
gone to
so
true love right yeah it is that's true
that's not often you follow a girl to
college and it actually works out
i sent him on ahead yeah we're high
school sweethearts but yeah i feel like
um
every little win that you get you got to
celebrate you don't have to go
extravagant or anything you just gotta
you got to find that little bit of of
success and once you find that success
you just keep building on it and
building on it and it's not only the
debt actually rolling off of you it's
the confidence that you get from it well
that's what i was asking about and i
didn't do a good job asking the question
what do you say to a dad sitting there
right now who over the last two years
been laid off
he's starting to look around and think i
think everybody around here would be a
little bit better if i just wasn't here
would you tell that guy i wrote
something down here that i realized and
some of it comes from listening to you
guys um i realize that i'm not a failure
i'm not a victim
and i'm not a villain
i was like all you have to do you have a
chance to be a hero and all you have to
do is just start
and that's what i did i had to convict
myself that
i can do something with my life i have
to find what that something is and i
just have to start today doing it and
like i said i had a lot of challenges
after that it didn't happen the next day
it happened
you know months and months later but it
was all that conviction of
you know the they're not better off
without me right yeah
that's a phrase right there i'm not a
failure
i'm not a victim yeah and i'm not a
villain and i just gotta start
and so i'm gonna start i'm gonna start
that's right i love it ashley what was
it like walking alongside
so again
i just
well when he started out when it was
just bad just kept reminding him no we
can't do this without you we got
two kids
we have little ones i think we had the
youngest one where he was still laid off
so he was i was like no they need you
they need your dad you're a good dad and
he has a good dad he's a fantastic dad
that's awesome and
i just kept reminding him
that we'd get there we'd get there we'd
get there that there's you know i
couldn't do this without him you all too
are amazing y'all are amazing thank you
so much for sharing that
that's powerful that's how it's done
that's exactly the number of people in
this country who are exactly where you
two are
is in the millions and you all are a
gift thank you yeah that's a that's a
powerful story
yeah um man
yeah
so i am not a failure so that means i'm
a success
i'm not a victim so that means i'm a
victor
and i'm not a villain so that means i'm
a hero yeah
oh i can be all those things i just got
to start yeah it's on the way man it's
on the way soon as you start you are
that's that's the thing man that's how
it works oh man love it
powerful stuff well done y'all we're
proud of you thank you thank you good
work good work and you brought the
kiddos in what are their names and ages
this is charlie he is four and this is
william he just turned eight the other
day all right very cool good looking men
all right we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story you will be baby
steps millionaires on your uh hero
journey here you're amazing well done
we're so proud of you guys and we got a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away and help somebody count it
down let's hear a debt free scream all
right come on boys
three two one
love it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today his new book is on
pre-sale own your past change your
future a not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
be sure and get it at
ramseysolutions.com
chad is with us chad is in indianapolis
hi chad welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave this is chad how are you better
than i deserve sir how can i help
hi dave i have a question about my
mortgage
my wife and i have enough money to pay
it off um we are on baby step four five
and six currently investing fifteen
percent of our income towards
investments
um i just have a question um we have
about over a hundred thousand dollars in
savings and our payoff for our house is
a little over eighty-five thousand
dollars
my goal is to pay it off here shortly
but i just wanted some advice i just get
nervous you know that fifteen thousand
dollar amount that would be left over is
a going to be about about three months
to six months emergency fund because we
would have no mortgage and we have no
debt um i just wanted to get some advice
as to what you think if we should pay it
off or we should um
and a little bit more background is
we're expecting some bonuses coming in
march that is pretty significant
and in april as well from our job how
much how much is significant what's that
mean how much money um so
uh forty thousand dollars between the
two of us in march
about seventeen thousand dollars in
april wow
wonderful
and i just i mean i just get nervous i
mean lots of times and things like that
because any job can be up for grabs and
if something would happen with a
downturn i mean i feel like my job's
safe but
who knows what the market and you know
things are trending with
supply chain and things like that i just
wanted to know
how long have you been at your job
i've been at mine for two years my wife
has been hers for five
you have any indication at all that
there's any kind of problem at either
one
not with mine no um but with her she's
in um
in her job she's in sales for tools with
stanley black and decker
and there was a layoff last month and um
we wanted
just to be safe with her job
my job's secure but i'm not sure with
hers
just because there was a layoff of a
thousand employees last month
if i woke up in your shoes i would write
a check today and pay off my house i
would have done it yesterday
but i close a business today okay
okay i can't think of anything that
makes me feel safer than having no
mortgage payment
okay
okay
something like that
you have gotten more you've done a very
good job of getting where you are and
you've gotten there by using some
powerful analytic tools that you have in
your brain you've got a strong brain
and you've gotten there by being
cautious
and conservative and the thing that got
you here is the thing is keeping you
from doing it
you're over analyzing this
pay it off
okay
and then in perfect 30 days you'll have
forty thousand dollars more yeah this
number will be fifty five 000 yeah
you're you're just fine you're just fine
you're gonna get your bonus and then
she's gonna keep her job it's just
you're fine yeah turn the news off yeah
hang out with your friends
for god's sakes turn the news off yeah
start hey that's the i was thinking i
was in the office a while ago we were
getting ready to start a meeting yeah
and they i've got the tv in there that
they put you know you can uh apple tv
where they put the computer up you know
and all this stuff so the people coming
in the team that was we're talking about
something they're gonna put it up on the
screen so they turn the tv on to um
uh
to get ready to put the computer
presentation on it right and the news
pops up
my brain just started melting
right there it just i i lost brain cells
before we could get it turned off i was
dumber i heard you yelling down the
street i'm down the hallway turn it on
young and the restless young and the
restless
bachelor
bachelor i didn't realize what you're
yelling about yeah
you know those two things didn't happen
you are a liar john deloney you are a
liar
oh sandy is in college station texas hey
sandy how are you
hey dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure i got a question for you um my
husband and i are both 62.
he's looking to retire sooner rather
than later
we're on 87 we have a net worth of about
2.4 million
of which 1.5 million is in retirement
accounts
we have a paid for home that's worth
about six hundred and fifty thousand
we have a very small lake cabin about a
hundred thousand
a rental home paid for a rental home
that's uh about worth about seventy five
thousand
[Laughter]
his salary right now is about 275 000 a
year
but as i said he's pretty much ready to
retire
we have when we when we paid for our
home we had our contractor build an
unfinished
two-bedroom apartment above my husband's
uh toy area
his three-car garage workshop okay
um and we're ready to finish that out
and we are trying to decide if we can go
ahead and just take the money out
of this retirement account since we're
over 62 or at 62 and just do it and pay
the tax implication or if we're missing
something okay just do it
it's a small percentage of your overall
world
okay
okay i'm just a little nervous because
of um you know we're gonna take it it's
not it's not enough money to be nervous
about
okay as a percentage of 2.4 million
what's the renault going to cost
uh probably between eighty and a hundred
thousand yeah if you if you took a
hundred thousand dollars out and burn it
in the fireplace your life isn't gonna
change
not substantially no
other than the fact you just wake up all
night screaming that you're that stupid
but
but no i mean the point my point is is
that you're actually creating an
investment here you're just you're
transferring the investment from one
type of investment to another because
you're increasing the value of the
property by more than a hundred thousand
dollars worth of investment can i ask
you a hard question sandy
sure john i've i've known some folks who
make the kind of salary your husband
makes
and there's it's easy to tie safety and
identity to that amount of money how
much of your concern is about pulling
the money out and how much of its
concern is
we're about to not be that couple that
makes that kind of money every month
well you have a valid point
we yeah it was it was a long road for us
to get to that point and of course
both of us um my husband fortunately is
a retire also retired military it has a
very good um
pension uh for his 27 years in
um but he's he he's of the mind oh i
don't want to touch any of this right
ever
and let's just let it grow for the kids
and i know this is growing this is
growing for the kids
that's true because what you're doing is
you're liquidating mutual fund
investments and you're putting it in
real estate
and when the kids come they can have
their own bathroom and that's going to
make everybody love each other a little
bit more right
amen
right mic drop okay this is an
investment in your family that's right
but the but the value of your property
is going to go up equivalent to what
you're spending on it
because this this apartment will have
will add to the opportunity
and so you're just you're just changing
you know you're just changing the asset
you're not you're not consuming it yeah
you're not taking a hundred thousand
dollars out and
blowing it on something that you can't
you're actually going to increase the
value of your your net worth it's not
going to change right that's my point if
you consumed it your net worth would go
down by that much so you're you're in
really really really good shape yeah
well done yes that's that's pot that's
powerful dave i do i do talk so that's a
good that's a really good insight i
missed that speaking to somebody this
weekend who's thinking about making a
major life change their family and
they have more money than they know to
do with but the the salary at the new
job is substantially less and it was
just a mindset
i'm gonna i used to be a guy that made
this much and i'm gonna be a guy that
makes this much and it didn't affect the
their lifestyle their net worth but it's
just it was an identity and he i think
he was struggling with i didn't realize
that attached it to that yeah and you
know what it'll sneak up on you oh yeah
yeah even if you're someone who's you
know like in my case i i teach people
not to have your identity in your stuff
don't have your identity in your in your
career don't have your identity but you
know i i um
i struggle with it you know i i think if
i if there was ever a day i stepped away
from this microphone which i'm not
planning to i think it'd be very hard
for me from an identity standard that's
right so
even though i don't i like to think it's
not who i think i am but i think when i
did it it would probably be oh yeah you
know for sure there you go
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host dr john deloney
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five as we talk about your mental health
your relationships your job your career
and your money your life all right here
on the ramsey show
phone number again triple eight eight
two five five two two five russ is with
us russ is in south bend indiana hi russ
welcome to the ramsey show
hello dave appreciate what you're doing
god bless you sir you too sir what's up
and uh well i'm in my fpu i'm uh last
night we did steps four through seven
uh my situation is this uh recently came
into some money through the sale of my
house
uh recently got married about nine days
ago
and a couple years ago i was not in this
good financial position and i took out a
debt uh reduction or debt negotiation
contract
with this organization i don't know now
i'm i'm paying off everything in fact um
we wrote a check today to pay off my
wife's uh house
wow that's out of the way we have the uh
the emergency fund does she have a
separate house than you
no no i sold my house
and now i'm moving in with her
y'all just got married yeah okay yeah
nine days ago okay okay
so my question is this
how do i handle this debt reduction
thing that's hanging over my head i'd
like to get out of it completely but i'm
in this contract it involves monthly
payments i uh call them today and ask
them is it better for me to just go to
the creditors myself directly and write
them checks or do i hang in with you
they indicated you know should hang in
with them well yeah
yeah
well yeah i know like asking a dog if
it's hungry
should we continue to collect fees from
you or not let me think about this
yeah no you need to and you don't have
to cancel the contract you just stop
giving them money it'll all end
just stop giving them money yeah yeah
stop stop giving that company money that
that's doing this um
debt repayment plan how many creditors
are involved
well now it's down to three originally
you'd start out with about a dozen okay
we'll just call those three
and negotiate a deal with each one of
them
were you behind with them in this
process probably
yeah and of course since i got in this
uh this debt reduction thing a couple
years ago there's been no phone calls no
harassment nothing let's call them up
here just call them up and ask for uh
and say okay i'm gonna i'll i'm in a
position to pay this off if you give me
a deal
now what kind of deal can we make
okay now one of the things that was told
me today when i called this debt
reduction company is well you're taking
a big risk if you do that they might get
aggressive with you we've got you
covered by this uh litigation firm
that'll stand up for you if they do get
that kind of aggressive so it kind of
scared me
but you're saying
just don't pay them and
talk to the creditors no worry i guess
huh
you have the money to pay him
i do
why would you worry about being
aggressive
well it's been a long time since they've
received a payment from me i don't know
it's okay
you're the customer on the account they
love money they and if you call them up
and go how much can i pay you
i i don't think they're i don't have to
worry about them being aggressive you
also have this awesome feature on your
phone called uh do not answer you can
hit that too
yeah they're not going to get aggressive
that's that's just company god man these
guys are evil
not only not only did not only they use
a scare tactic to keep you on the hook
russ you're talking about these guys
like they're your friends yeah
and like they don't have a con like they
don't have a conflict of interest in
this stupid butt advice they're giving
you
they want to keep you on the line they
want to keep you and keep you paying
them fees
and you're saying just stop paying them
how do you get away with that
you stop paying the company that you're
talking to on the phone that's giving
you this bad advice instead you call the
creditors and you ask each of the three
creditors a simple question
i'm going to write a check and pay this
off today if you will make me a deal
get what's the deal
and send that to me in email in written
form you keep that in writing and you
send them that money
okay it's and it goes away there's not
just that simple it's only they're only
going to get aggressive the the
creditors the three creditors if they
don't get money
do you have enough to pay all three of
them off yeah
yeah i do yeah
congratulations you're gonna be a free
man today yeah it'll take you it'll take
you two weeks to get through the crap
here but but um you're gonna have to
have a you know back and forth
conversation with them and force them to
give it to you in writing do not give
them money till you get it in writing
and do not give them electronic access
to your checking account but you this
company is not your friend
they're debt con solidation companies
that's what we call them
and do i negotiate with these creditors
or just give them what they're asking
for i i would at i would say uh what is
the balance
and what kind of deal can you make me
okay
because these are all bad debts
that you've been paying payments on bad
debts
they would love to get your butt off
their books
okay and they probably will give you an
offer of 50 to 70 cents on the dollar
when one phone call
well that sounds pretty good yeah of
whatever the balance is do you have any
idea what the actual balance is today
yes okay so you can you can kind of
you've got some basis point to know if
the company this creditor when you call
them is lying to you then so you can go
okay wait a minute the number i've got
is this what are you showing is the
balance and if i wrote a check today and
paid this off what kind of deal would
you give me
because i'm thinking about doing that
okay if you give me a good enough deal
they've probably turned this over to
collection companies and that's probably
who i'll be talking to doesn't matter
they're the same thing they want money
okay everyone here wants your money if
they if they sold the debt they sold it
for a nickel on the dollar
and so they sold a thousand dollar debt
for 50 bucks
and if that's who you're talking to that
bought your thousand dollar debt for 50
bucks you're gonna get a really good
deal when you do what i do when you do
what i just told you to do
so
no you are uh you act like that these
guys
uh have magic powers over this other
company they don't have magic powers
they're just doofuses or if it sounds
like you feel like you fell into a river
and these guys showed up on a night on
like horses with
i don't know swords and things and
pulled you out of the river and saved
you
and
they didn't they didn't
they didn't you were in the river and
they threw you a concrete block so here
hold this
okay that's
and oh by the way there's a fee for the
block there's a few for the block
yeah so no these are not your friends
this is
slimy i've never heard somebody with
that level of like
his heartbeats for this company no he's
just he's worried they they they'll
scare you huh they took care of him when
he was scared yeah he they got the
creditors off of him that's right and
they got a plan and he's just been
working that plan he don't want to upset
that apple cart yeah and then they
pushed on that button because they knew
that was the button to use
and that that's keeping him in the
saddle here which is a bad plan
yeah call the three creditors get you a
deal write them a check get it in
writing no electronic access to your
checking account
get it in writing
no electronic access to your checking
account and you got a deal and you'll be
out of this and within two weeks
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at aaa
825-5225
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money steven is with us in
indianapolis hi stephen welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave how are you great man what's up
hey one just want to say a big fan you
guys got me and my wife out of debt over
the last couple years so i'm following
your method so i just want to say i'm a
huge fan of yours and uh thanks for
taking my call well done um
yes sir on this one now i'm calling for
my sister she is historically bad with
money and she's a little help um
she had a car
had it paid off in cash at one point and
needed like three thousand dollars worth
of work so she did something i don't
agree with she traded in
got a loan at a buy here pay here for a
car that's not even worth its own weight
now
and now this car
needs about
2500 worth of work the car is only worth
about three thousand dollars and she
owes ten thousand dollars on this loan
so my question is how can she get out of
this car into something more reliable
without taking out another loan and
rolling negative equity and going into
debt
she's screwed
i know yeah
i mean there's not a move here uh she's
gonna be in debt she's ten thousand
dollars in debt and she has an asset
that's not worth two thousand bucks
right did i understand that right
yeah yeah
and so she has an eight thousand dollar
hole
and there's the only way to cover that
is eight thousand dollars and that's
going to come from somewhere
so um
yeah obviously we're not gonna do a deal
with these people again so
uh but
let me tell you what they will do
it's a buy here pay here
their uh
repo rate
back onto that lot
is very very high
because of this situation because people
get that people
instead of asking a question like you're
asking they get in these situations and
they just drive up and toss the keys in
the window and keep walking
and um
and that's standard in that business so
you know like
let's just say among a regular car like
you go to a ford dealer and get a ford
motor company ford motor credit loan
let's just say that the repo rate there
is three percent
the repo rate in a tote the note lot is
probably 40
you see what i'm saying
and the reason is is they're selling the
car for twice as much as it's worth
and they're got payments on it and then
it's a piece of crap car and they ends
up breaking anyway and they get in the
same mess and so they're used to dealing
with her my point is they probably will
negotiate that eight down if she goes
somewhere else and gets a loan gives
them real money
like they will for sure okay so i would
send her like to the credit union
and uh off you know offer them once she
gets a loan arranged with the credit
union maybe she gets a 5 000 loan and uh
offer them the car back
and the uh
and two thousand dollars
they'll probably take it
take the other take the other three
thousand and buy a car anywhere else but
a place like that
yeah go go get a five thousand dollar
loan at the credit union we're getting
rid of a ten thousand dollar loan with
this transaction you following me
yep i'm calling you so i'm i'm not
borrowing i mean i'm borrowing money but
we've already got borrowed money we're
just making it better
so you take you you go then you go over
there are you in town the same town with
her
no again this goes back to her being
that with money she ended up moving down
to texas where the cost of living is a
lot more than is here in indianapolis so
she's is she got any family in that town
where she is
no unfortunately both our parents pass
away and that's another reason she
wanted to move just to kind of get away
and restart because um
just having dealt with these folk all
the time for the last 30 years
uh
here's here's a best case scenario i'm
not sure we can pull it off but if she
can go get a 5 000 loan with the credit
union
uh buy an airline ticket and go down
there
get in get her car and her and drive
over to that lot
and you sit down in front of that
manager
it creates a different vibe in that
world than her doing it
okay and you can go ahead and get up in
his grill if you want for being a crook
as a part of this transaction and go
look dude if you think you're getting
ten thousand dollars out of this broke
woman you is what's known as confused
and so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna give you this car back that's a
piece of crap that you ripped her off
with in the first place and two thousand
dollars and you're gonna smile and
you're gonna like it aren't you
and that's
you can do that a whole lot better than
she can do it in that world you
following me
i'm following you and uh i'm serious
that that's about the verbiage and the
attitude i would use i'm not being
bombastic
because that you're you're in a rough
and tumble world there
so go go in there uh with that kind of
you know swagger and just go look we're
not doing this
you screwed her and so now you're gonna
make it right and you're gonna make
you're still gonna make a profit you got
your stupid car back and you got some
money you go on you live another day and
you let her go and this otherwise we're
gonna have a real problem here and we're
gonna have to get lawyers involved and
we're gonna have to get oh man it's just
gonna be messy and none of us wanna do
that so let's just to get us a deal done
right here
okay if you can pull if you can pull
that off in your schedule and buy 200
plane ticket fly down and help her
handle it
um
it sounds like i'm being sexist i'm not
but that world is right you're going to
get a different you're going to get a
different thing when you walk in there
than she will
and uh because you know they saw her
coming the first time
and she's going to reset in their brain
for them to not see her coming again
and that's that's what we're dealing
with well their entire business practice
is built on desperation well and
intimidation right yeah so we just flip
that on them a little
let's have a little discussion about
this
oh my goodness yeah that's that's the
thing so yeah
yeah
so here's the thing when you're when
guys when you're looking at stuff like
this in
uh lower income real estate
and lower income
uh which is what took the note is always
associated with
uh what what the the deal is not the
interest rate that they're charging you
it's that they're giving you terms
when no one else will give you terms
they'll put you on payments when no one
else will put you on payments and so
they're making a bazillion dollars by
changing the price of the item
not by charging a 30 interest rate they
may only charge a 20 interest rate
subprime interest rate but then double
the price of the car
[Music]
you buy a house i used to have friends
that would sell houses in these uh
low-income neighborhoods and they they'd
sell the house on weekly payments
pay payments weekly
and
with nothing down or 500 down you could
buy a house with weekly payments and all
the people heard was 500 down and weekly
that's all they heard they didn't hear
that the you know this house that's
worth in those days forty thousand
forty thousand bucks is being sold to
them for sixty uh
and the interest rate sounded pretty
good so until you factor in the fact
that they're over charging for the
actual item so much when you put that
back in as an interest rate now you got
a 400 percent interest rate i heard
there's a crackdown on those total notes
interest rates and i guess that's the
that's the way you fix it that's the way
you fix it that's it's not us
if it's just the price is ridiculous
yeah and people aren't they don't even
look at the price right oh they're
they're just desperate
can i get desperate intimidated scared
and and it's almost like that caller
earlier where the guy thinks that
they're doing him a favor that's right
and uh it's it's a it's a disastrous
scenario so same thing with like rent to
own yeah you know
if if if you need to rent your washer
and dryer
you don't need to buy a washer and dryer
yeah
period
you know and someone's taking you and so
here's the thing
you can kind of look too at the
groupings of these offerings if you
drive down the main drag of a lower
income end of town
all the things that you see there
are just about rip-offs the predatory
yeah tidal pawn pawn
uh
rent to own yeah uh
tote the note
you know it's all right there and it's
every one of them are screwing you yeah
and so and same thing if you're watching
tv
and your investment is in the same place
as a snuggie and a walk-in bathtub
then you probably don't have a good
investment
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage sean
and camille are with us hey guys how are
you hey doing good how are you better
than i deserve welcome where do you guys
live
clarksville tennessee all right right up
the road yeah well welcome to nashville
it's good to have you guys so how much
debt have you paid off
297
000
wow how long did that take about four
and a half years wow good for you and
your range of income during that time
130 up to 260.
nice jump what do you guys do for a
living i work in healthcare as a hr
director
i have an in-home business and then i
also do real estate on the side oh good
so what caused all this income increase
yeah no you went to work you took a job
and the real estate thing's going well
yeah yeah good for you good job so what
kind of debt was your 297 000. dave we
paid off her house yeah
look at that weird people yeah
there it is how old are you two i'm 33 3
by 33 that was our goal my goal she
looks
older than 23 years that's right i agree
i'm 35. way to go you guys that's so
cool what's this house worth probably
about 460.
i love it way to go that's a beautiful
house y'all
good looking property yeah
nicely done
nicely done so how much in your
investments in your retirement accounts
uh we were just talking about that about
150 in our retirement already so after a
good start there so you're going to be
babysitting millionaires in about three
years that's the plan yeah so before
you're 40 you'll be millionaires wow
that's crazy to think about
that is so stinking cool way to go thank
you oh that is amazing well tell us the
story what how did all this start four
and a half years ago
so i actually knew about you from
college um i'm a i'm a saver hoarder
he's a spender we got married we had
some financial struggles the first
couple years just not being on the same
page and
we finally
found you know started listening to you
a little bit more and um
just needed a plan i think we needed to
be on the same page that was the biggest
thing for us is you know i had one idea
and he had another idea and we're like
we need to we need something that works
that we can both go back to
so
we paid off our consumer debt the first
couple years of marriage was like 25 000
and then we kind of followed the baby
steps and then we got pregnant with
our first little one and we were like
all right we're gonna do this we're
gonna go for it and so that was about
four and a half years ago
and we just started buckling down
getting really serious making some
sacrifices and so what made you two come
and say all right ramsay is the plan
we're gonna do and we're both gonna
commit to that
yeah i think we uh we knew of dave plans
for a while but again four and a half
years ago we got pregnant so we decided
we better kick it into gear so we got
connected we went to fpu uh we've
actually started uh coordinating the
class we have our art coordinator over
here as well
uh got connected with the church as well
but family and friends uh definitely had
the support system around us okay all
right so the financial peace university
class convinced you that that's the way
yeah and that gave you both the same
sheet of music to sing from absolutely
the biggest thing for me i think that
pulled me in and probably for you too
was the changing your family tree
um i'm the oldest of six kids and we you
know there was never a lot of money
and so um it's kind of emotional
there was just always fights involving
it and i just was like i don't want to i
don't want to live that way um i don't
want to fight about money and i wanted
something better for our kids so that
was the thing that just over and over
again i was like we got to change our
family tree we can do this and i'm very
um i understand about making decisions
and i'm very motivated and so i you know
i it just made sense it was simple it
was easy to do i'm a checklist person i
could get him on board he's in hr so
which could be challenging at times i
know i'm a spender at heart so but um
yeah just stay connected and get with
the plan and yeah
it's amazing so i'm looking at this
timeline here and you grew another human
in between this
how in the world you stay on this
plan and
have yet another
new person in your home that it was hard
it was that i mean people make it sound
like it's easy it is not easy um they're
15 months apart i basically had two
under two for a while and um 2020 for
everybody i think was kind of a disaster
and it was really hard
we had some family stuff that kind of
went down and um
i think part of me just was like i i've
got to focus on something i've gotta
i've gotta get my mind on something
that's positive something that makes me
feel like we're winning so many people
focused on tiger king and you
did it
of course you did that's fun but you
focused on something that right you took
that that time when everything was in
smoke and rubble and you said i'm gonna
build something great out of this that's
incredible yeah and it's funny because
once you actually like get really
serious and i mean we didn't need to do
beans and rice per se we just worked our
butts off and
it just it was so good like it was it
just have something that was positive
when the world felt like it was falling
apart and i was like
at least i just want to sleep it good at
night like i just want this weight off
of me
um well when you can't control anything
if you find something you can finally
control it's worth doing yeah absolutely
you're spinning out otherwise yeah yeah
exactly the sense of i at least i can
control this part exactly so let's do
that and that that's somewhat keeps you
sane when everything's just going fall
flying off the handle yes you know so
wow very powerful what was your best
disagreement
that's disagreement
you know we didn't have a ton
i just looked at the hr director's face
he's got one i saw it
what do you have
i think it's the budgets in general just
to just stay on track so of course every
month just looking at that and
yeah you got to change something right
so i'm always annoyed by just sitting
down and reviewing it but i think it's a
good a good thing to do but yeah no no
well let me say this so he had some
things he wanted when we paid the house
off because i'm the penny puncher
and so we we he got a hot tub yeah and
it's tight in season tickets yeah oh
sorry ding ding when we were struggling
i was like we're not doing that we're
not doing i was like okay we can do that
when you live like no one else later you
get the season tickets in the hot tub
there you go that's how it works yeah
wow perfect pretty cool man pretty cool
man seems like a fair trade today three
by thirty three that's that's a slogan
that's a slogan
everyone has i told everybody that they
probably all thought i was crazy i don't
know i we for sure did 100 they did yeah
we got support but people are just kind
of like okay you go do that that's good
for you and i'm good at doing stuff that
people look at me like you're weird but
that's perfect i'm fine being weird yeah
you you're the best kind of weird
because when it comes to money normal
sucks you don't be normal it comes to
most things normal sucks you don't be
normal so you guys are powerful well
done very well done we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story we've
already run the math it's only going to
be a couple years for you you're going
to be there
very cool and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and get
someone else stirred up one of those
people who thought you were weird maybe
now they'll listen to you how you like
me now
yeah i like it i like it and you got the
kiddos you want to put them in the shot
yeah absolutely all right what are their
names and ages dallas is four and dakota
just turned three through all right here
we go all right kiddos i love it i love
it changed your family tree you did it
well done all right it's shawn and
camille dallas and dakota from
clarksville tennessee 297 thousand 000
paid off house and everything they're
weird four and a half years making 130
to 260. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream you ready dallas
[Music]
[Applause]
10 years old they watch that video
mom and dad doing that debt-free scream
back when i was four
and that's when the family tree changed
yep
that's how that branch of the family
became some of the first millionaires in
that family that's how that branch of
the family never fought about money
again that's how that branch of the
family ended up in that church that's
how that thank you financial peace
university coordinators for teaching
that at your local church look what
happens when you do i'm so proud of you
wow
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well how are your resolutions going out
there folks if you're like most people
uh you hit january hard but by
valentine's day you were done you tapped
out don't tap out
we can actually show you how to turn
your resolutions into actual goals that
are achievable in bite size and uh you
will stay on the plan you'll keep moving
we do that like you just heard a minute
ago in financial peace university you go
through this class and you will not only
learn the steps you'll have people
around you encouraging you to do the
steps holding you accountable to the
steps it's a proven plan that almost 10
million people have been through now
right now there's hundreds of financial
peace universities classes getting
started both in person and online
good time for you to jump in right now
no lame resolutions actual adult-like
goals make 2022 the year you get control
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash
fpu
yesterday john we put uh
the
smart conference on sale in dallas
we're going to go out there october the
22nd you and me and the ramsey
personalities ken coleman george
campbell craig groeschel and amy
groschel our friends from life church
over in oklahoma city are going to be
teaching on marriage
um you'll be teaching from the new book
own your past change your future uh we
might have a little baby steps
millionaires action in there could
happen too uh and uh you know ken
coleman of course about careers and
rachel will be there pedro will be there
christina will be there courtney will be
there eddie will be there all the ramsey
personalities are going to be there the
whole gang
whole dad blamed bunch
the whole fam family that is going to be
a loud plane ride
you know what it will be it may drive
myself it will be because i'm going to
take an uber to
you know there's a couple of these
people never shut up so yeah you're
probably right that could be interesting
but i'll tell you what they all got
something to say yes they do and the
smart conference especially with amy and
greg being craig being there on the
marriage subjects just gonna be
incredible so if you don't have your
tickets yet they went on sale the early
bird specials are still out there you
can get a deal if you go ahead and
purchase them now we're so excited to be
back in the arenas back in the
marketplace
back out here doing events again it is
our favorite thing to do we've all
missed it around here we've missed you
guys so we're kicking it off with this
smart conference in dallas october 22nd
stay tuned we're going to do some
building wealth events in a bunch of
other cities
starting the spring over into the fall
we'll be announcing those really really
soon so just count on it ramsay's
rolling back out baby we're gonna let
the big wheel roll time to get after it
again
time to get things moving you can get
all of that information at
ramseysolutions.com
and just click on events you can find
everything that we're doing there we've
got the entree leadership summit in may
in orlando
we're going to be adding some stuff to
that orlando day we're going to be down
around that area doing a bunch of stuff
so you people in orlando get ready just
getting ready go ahead and tell you
there's going to be some announcements
coming your way in addition to the
entree leadership summit so
uh we we've just made a decision around
here for to get moving again can't wait
i've been on the road the fall fall and
doing smaller events and i can't wait to
get back out and do some
big stuff man yeah i'm going over to
elevation church and speak for steven
furtick yeah in a couple weeks in march
uh he he texted me the other day and
wonderful church steven's been a friend
for a lot of years i'm going over in uh
life church and speak for craig yeah uh
as well uh he's a little little bitty
old church he's got yeah he's a tiny
little thing a tiny little operation
over there largest church in america 80
000 people or something yeah it's it's
it's it's a lot
it's a lot
so um hey it's a lot of stuff happening
and here we go baby game on game on so
uh
if you uh
you know if you got a friend
that you've been trying to get to do
this stuff you know you need to get
tickets smart conference go and buy them
tickets too
and get them there you some of these
other events you hear us doing them you
need to bring somebody you tell people
about it and by the way i don't say that
very often on this show but um i've been
remiss
to not ask you guys that are listeners
to help us
by telling your friends to listen yeah
if you're listening on podcast or
youtube or on your local radio station
or siriusxm spread the word
this is where you get the ramsey show
and it's life-changing information here
um it's not because it's mine it's god's
and grandma's ways of handling money and
life and uh none of us invented these
things we just uh put a package to them
and teach them in such a way that
they're ingestible and that you can
really use them to change your life oh
and by the way you could have crap on
instead of something that's helpful
right and so you got to decide what
you're going to put in your brain you
keep putting crap in your brain your
brain's going to be crap it's time for
you to get with some people and get out
of your house you know go do stuff
together yeah these kind of things can
spark entire
communities to change it can friend
groups to change family groups to change
get a couple of folks and come out i
don't think people realized
um
consciously until the last few months
how
much
uh
this idea that man is not good for men
to be alone
this isolation
uh from other people
how
psychologically damaging it is
and it was re it's also revealing
simultaneously to me the weak spots in
uh this social media
where people don't have real friends
they have facebook friends and by the
way your facebook friends are not real
friends they're fake friends
okay and so unless they also happen to
be your friend who you actually see
in the flesh and look at them in their
real eyes
and that kind of thing and so your
followers on instagram are not real
that's not real that's right i've got i
got what have i got two million on
instagram yeah and you know how many of
them i know personally three
[Laughter]
yeah you and james and kelly you and
james and kelly that's three my wife
yeah rachel yeah i know all of y'all no
my wife doesn't follow me so i don't
know and so
and uh you know and and you know you get
these it's funny so many people that
think they know something about social
media go oh ramsay you're doing this all
wrong man you only follow 33 people and
you have two million people following
you you're supposed to follow a
bazillion people man you're doing it all
wrong i'm like no you you're doing it
wrong
because you forgot the idea that human
connection is a big deal it's everything
that's why we're relishing going to
football games yeah that's why we're
relishing going to an eagles concert
it's why we're relishing going to a
ramsey smart conference because we're in
the presence of other human beings that
have like-minded
uh goals and values and we're aiming at
something together uh we're not sitting
somewhere looking at a screen
and calling it a conversation somebody i
was on an interview the other day and
they asked me was the try it was about
trauma and
the interviewer asked me dude i think
this trauma that we just experienced
we're experiencing coming out of was on
par with 911
as a country and i said no i think this
one's actually worse oh definitely
because 911 we had at least we had
whether it's an illusion we had a common
enemy yeah and it was them and this time
it was
well maybe that woman walking her dog
might kill me or maybe my kid coming
home from school mike what's happening
and we weaponized each other right i
went to get
you know i went to buy a loaf of bread
in there and all of a sudden you know
i'm a villain yeah or someone's going to
kill you or you're going to kill all
these other people and we weaponized the
most core human function
which is human connection it just turned
into a weapon and then it got
politicized and then we all it went
crazy it was crazy and we went from
flattening the curve to masking to
vaccine to beating each other up with
the curve to everything else and just
panicking yeah and the uh the the it was
yeah it was much more devastating than
911 yeah to the the fractured the psyche
to the culture yeah to the culture it's
gonna be a long time digging out of this
one
but there's the antidote it's other
people it is relationships in person all
day every day real relationships in
person this is the antidote so not only
what happened there but what has
happened with the this fake social media
revolution is being exposed now as fake
uh facebook's tanking consequently it's
tanking
uh because people are starting to go is
not real well that's why we called it
virtual well
it's back in the day when they used to
give my granddad i think it was one of
his teachers or a coach gave him
cigarettes because it calmed him down
when he was 10.
and
it worked it did and then we realized oh
that'll kill you too right so yeah this
was all fun and games for a couple of 10
years or 15 years till we realized oh
man it's gonna kill us all so yeah we
gotta get back in the same room with
each other talk to each other again
and you know attend some things i'm
making myself go do i am things in the
presence and i'm making our organization
start to do these events yeah and even
if it's uncomfortable and even if some
of you out there are pissed off just go
ahead and get really pissed off because
we're doing it
okay because i i know you're scared and
i understand you're scared i'm sorry
you're scared but we're doing it we're
going to get back out here and and help
people again and move the dead gum
needle and if you don't like that well
you don't have to come it's that easy
come anyway but we'd like to have you
anyway come anyway well don't come if
you're miserable don't come don't make
everybody miserable that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status simple of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the dr
john deloney podcast which is ever so
popular on the ramsey networks is my
co-host today as we talk about your
relationships
your mental health your boundaries your
family
your work your career and your money we
talk about all these things on ramsey
every day we're glad you're here the
ramsay show triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number and uh
mitchell is with us in south lake tahoe
california
hey mitchell what's up hello dave how's
it going better than i deserve how can
we help
um so i've been following your show for
about a year now and
um
i have a tip based job and i make
minimum wage but
with the tips it's hard to kind of
follow all of all the rules and stuff um
i'm trying to figure out what i should
do like my next step you know what i
mean cool so you're not making minimum
wage you're making good money serving
right
yeah it's actually uh i'm a limo driver
i'm a chauffeur oh okay what do you make
what's your total you're making in a
week
tips and tips and pay
i would say total
probably 800 a week and on average
good for you good for you yeah okay
here's the way you need to do a budget
and all the rules do work you just got
to use them a little differently okay
right what i want you to do is i want
you to make a list and you could do it
you could start doing it with a yellow
pad you can use the every dollar app and
modify it and use it this way as well
but let's just do it on a yellow pad
right now in your mind so you can follow
the principle okay just get a yellow pad
out in your head you see it in your head
right now
i do yeah okay now make a list down that
page of every single thing you need to
do with money or want to do with money
this month and just start putting dollar
amounts beside all of it all the way
down that page in your mind you don't
have to do them all right now but that's
what you're gonna do
then once you get that list made i want
you to look at that list and say if i
only make enough money to buy one thing
because this month sucks what is the
most important thing on this page i'll
help you with that it's food
put a number one beside food and put a
dollar amount beside it
okay i literally cut run so i think
that's wrong yeah well rent's gonna be a
little bit down the ways but you'll get
there in a minute okay number two is
utilities
number three is rent
because you got to keep the lights on
and then pay the rent if you pay the
rent and don't have any lights you you
get cold
right so we're gonna but you got enough
easy to do these three things anyway so
you put dollar amounts beside you go
food
utilities shelter you have a car payment
um no i actually
after i started watching i got debt free
so i was pretty happy wonderful way to
go way to go okay so now you just keep
going down the list and say okay what's
the next most important thing and put a
number beside what's the next most
important thing put a number beside it
what's the next most important thing and
you put a number beside it so you got 1
through 36 or whatever it is down the
page
in order of importance in order of
priority are you following me
i do yeah and they all have a dollar
amount beside them so when you get some
money from a paycheck or a tip
you look at you look at the list and
wherever you are on the list you start
there and work your way down
and so the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to set some money aside
in an envelope for food we write food on
the envelope we set that in the kitchen
drawer and we don't buy anything from
that envelope except food and we don't
buy any food except from that envelope
and that keeps you right on budget then
the next thing you're going to do is
you're going to pay your electric bill
the next money you get you're going to
go and pay your rent the next money you
get you're going to do the next thing
and the next money you get you're going
to do the next thing and every so often
you're going to draw lines through the
ones above that you've done and you can
rewrite the list a matter of fact you
could do it once a week and rewrite the
list because it might change a little
bit from week to week
it does yeah every week yeah not only
your income no because we don't know how
far down the list you're going to go
because we don't know exactly what your
tips are going to be you could have a
1200 a week or you could have a 600 a
week we don't know right
exactly yeah yeah so we don't know how
far down the list you're going to get
this week but you do have a list and
every dollar that you're going to make
is already spent because the list needs
to be longer than you're going to make
right
but let's say let's say you're in the
third week of this and the rent's
already paid and the lights are already
paid the food's already in the cabinets
when you rewrite the list you don't have
to put those on next week next week's
going to be a week where you get to do
some stuff down in there like paying off
debt or putting some money in savings or
increasing your generosity or something
like that and so but you've got a
prioritized
list and john this is how sharon and i
lived with that literal yellow pad there
was no internet there was no apps we had
a yellow pad like that and because i was
in the real estate business when i first
started doing these principles and i
would have a month where i would make
twenty thousand dollars and i'd have a
month where i made zero yeah and so
we were taking some of that money and
setting it up for the next month if we
had a big month
and we're but we're going through
food if we make just a little bit of
money we eat
first thing we do
you know kids got to eat yeah got babies
it's a formula and diapers and you know
we got to go to the grocery store what's
the next thing we're going to do we'll
keep the lights on and the heat on yeah
the cool the air conditioner on and
what's the next thing we're going to do
we're going to keep the house you know
and you can usually get your basic life
done
and then you start to relax a little bit
emotionally because your your survival
is now guaranteed you're you're
sustainable right
and but that priority that those yellow
pads um
sharon was telling one of our friends at
dinner the other night that she said and
we kept another yellow pad of goals that
we want to knock off big things we want
to do we want to do this we want to do
this we want to do this and we had that
prioritized
and
so as we got a little extra money you
know like we're driving a piece of crap
car we had to get her a better car
and so that's a goal that's over on
another yellow pad and we would just
jump back and forth between the yellow
pads but it was all about listing
and prioritization and then it gives you
something to work for that's right and
intentionality he can if he's got
something he's trying to hit he can take
an extra shift that's right he can take
that ride that he doesn't want to take
after midnight which is gross a lot of
times you know limo you know and so uh
or he could take up you know a sunday
morning early to the airport that he
didn't want to get up at four but he can
go take that if he's trying to hit a
goal because he can get that extra tip
and if you don't have anything to live
for if you don't have anything to work
towards you just because it's not listed
out you just go why do i work you know
and you spin your wheels out but you'll
increase your income doing this but you
also have a few weeks to look at
oh i may not hit my food i need to come
up with something and it doesn't
surprise you week of or day off right
you can see it coming yeah
because there is a plan that's right and
the point is you're still
spending every dollar on paper on
purpose before the month begins
don't wait till you get the check people
to try to figure out what you're gonna
do with the check
always have it already spent
already assigned before it comes to you
to something before it comes to you
always do that the rest of your life and
i even do that with high net worth
people
high income earners like i was with the
nfl guy the days getting a
multi-million dollar bonus coming
and um had a good year and uh he's like
what do i do with this and i said i
don't know but let's go ahead and do it
before you get it yeah you know put a
percentage on it okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna live on ten percent of it and have
a great life
you know and i'm gonna give
an extra 10
and i'm gonna invest
and whatever it is you got you need to
give those dollars an assignment before
you get them because what happens is you
will spend that check that's coming oh
man like 10x so fast in your head yeah
you you spend it 10 times yeah you act
like it's 10 times more money than it is
5 to 10 times more money it's not as
much money as your little brain thinks
it is until you put it on paper
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america over the
last 30 years i've walked with tens of
thousands of people and their families
to help them overcome their financial
stress we found money stress is one of
all the kinds of ways that we actually
experience stress
there's anxiety and loneliness there's
all kinds of crazy in our families we've
had lies told about us well-meaning
people not well-meaning people there's
all kinds of trauma that happens in our
lives the good news is the guy sitting
to my right dr john deloney my co-host
today has a brand new book out called
own your past change your future it's
available for pre-order today it'll help
you deal with all kinds of trauma get
connected to a community make friends as
an adult and the steps that you can take
to change your thoughts and actions
and you get free bonus items when you go
ahead and buy it for twenty dollars now
including a month of one-on-one therapy
with the folks at betterhelp and you get
the audiobook and you get the ebook and
all kinds of other stuff it's several
hundred dollars worth of stuff total
package and so you really it's an
unbelievable deal to buy this book for
twenty dollars in pre-order and john i
that the thing that is
i can't wait to get this book out in a
while i can't either man yeah where
people start
i i because i've got i i think i know
what's going to happen
with it um but but it's just but i i am
a little bit worried maybe i got forced
in the trees you know i mean i'm i'm too
close to it because i read it before
anybody else hardly and i mean there's
like six or eight of us in the reading
group as you're putting it together and
uh but what's happened here is the not
so complicated approach uh to
relationships mental health and wellness
you took a
very complicated subject of what happens
in our bodies our brains
in our emotions and our psychology when
we are when we all have trauma when we
have trauma a big t little t trauma
and uh broke it down
came at it
through a different door than i've ever
seen before this the i just think the
power of story
is everything and you use stories to
talk about how we're dealing with this
yeah it
most of us don't know that the the loops
that we just live on a loop man we just
live on a loop and live on a loop but
these things that we were born into the
things we were told and yeah
you know it was a it was a i just was
talking to some folks from my old higher
ed days last week
and i was talking to them about how
convicting it was i spent the last 20
years talking with brilliant people
wonderful people we talked about
theories and ideas and maps let's look
at the data and then i came here and
it's every day talking to that single
mom and that dad who just wants to be
better and this family that can't seem
to get over the hump
and i realize this is i'm not indicting
anybody else other than myself i've been
speaking past people for 20 years i've
been trafficking in ideas and theories
and i had not been about how can i help
this person right here hurting right now
put the cookies on the shelf before we
can reach them
and what purpose is any of the
highfalutin thinking that we're doing
exactly if we're not doing that so yeah
this book was the number of people who
reach out and say hey man could would
you do private coaching would you do be
my therapist i can't do that
this is as close as i could get to
sitting across the table from somebody
saying i love you i'm gonna sit with you
and let's do this together because i've
been through it too man right i've been
buried by this stuff too and i've been
married we'll celebrate 20 years this
year
yesterday on the flight home in the
middle of the night i thought i don't
know you right so i'm living this too
and um
man i i haven't been more proud of
something i think probably my entire
professional career than this thing i'm
excited for it the notes that i'm
getting back here's the cool stuff
it's the notes from the people we're
getting working on the email campaign
that say hey i had to read this my boss
made me
and oh man right it's it's the folks who
don't normally resp write me notes
it's i'm excited for it yeah it's
um
it is a subject that is very rarely put
within reach of us mortals there you go
and you put it in reach of people like
me where i can see it i know i now
understand it and i know exactly what to
do with it and
it's not that it's oversimplified or
dumbed down
it just takes a lot of brain power to
take a complicated thing and make it
simple can i tell you the truth i wrote
it for me because
i can distance myself from the
complexity of things
and then be sitting there on my phone
when my six-year-old wants to talk to me
i can know all this stuff so this book
is not overly simple at all it's hard
but it's for me right it's for all of us
and it's it's not for
i don't know i'm excited about it man uh
own your past yeah i'm excited about it
change your future so the stories that
we're telling ourselves that are holding
us back the stories that we're telling
ourselves that are weighing us down we
can write new stories that's exactly
right and that's what it comes down to
it's it's the it's the new third way man
there's that crew telling you that
this happened to you and you're gonna be
a victim the rest of your life you can't
move and we saw somebody earlier today
i refuse to be a victim any longer right
and then you got the other side that's
you know feelings don't feelings aren't
real just grind it and keep going this
is a new third way man you got to own
that stuff and then you got to say what
comes next yeah yeah and i'm going to
say that it's real and then i'm going to
put it in the rear view mirror and then
i'm gonna get to going about living my
life what comes next yeah i really went
through bankruptcy
but it's not it and it changed the
trajectory of my life but it didn't
define the entirety of my life that's
right and i would even say you've never
said this out loud
i would say there's a part if you and i
were to spend 10 hours together
that there were some guys who put on
some seminars that took advantage of a
25 year old kid who really wanted to do
right in the world and wanted to you
know like hey just do these things right
there's even some
you you're good about taking ownership i
own all that but there are some folks i
think that would take advantage of young
kids right things happen to you and then
you said okay here's my participation in
this and now what am i going to do
starting tomorrow okay what am i going
to do when i wake up and do this and so
whether people did stuff to you you
participated in i don't care how we got
to here
you got to oh well what i crap yeah and
then go but yeah it's not it's not a
completely
thing where i tell you you know we we
had some bankers
that completely broke the law there you
go that's right you got it and and and
we're doing some things that
absolutely
i mean
we're ignoring we're straight straight
up immoral and illegal and and forced
you know because they thought we were
going broke and they were scared about
their portfolio and they were going
after us and they you know created a
self-fulfilling prophecy uh so that yeah
there's a part they played in that the
tax law changed under reagan reagan
there's a part he played in me going
broke you know uh there there's a part
that um and i'm a ronald reagan fan you
know but you know that happened the law
screwed up the banking system right and
uh made the snl's go broke yeah and uh
we had a bunch of stuff with snl's and
so you know there's yeah and yeah there
was get rich quick seminars that i
bought into the crap and uh
but uh
i can't really affect all of that you
can affect none of it the only thing i
can affect is
what you i did and i go okay so i'm not
going to put myself where i'm vulnerable
to those kinds of people ever again
that's right never again you know it's
really going to be hard for american
express to call my house and try to
you know yell at my wife about a bill
that's unpaid because we will never do
business with american express again i'm
not gonna be susceptible to them
under any circumstances
and so if american express calls my
house it's a wrong number right you know
or a robo call for a warranty on the car
you know what i mean oh my god and you
talked about in an earlier segment your
path out wasn't pretty it was you and
your wife and a couple of yellow pads
right
it's not like nothing
there was no mana no
it was two people on a yellow pad the
grind out of this thing is hard
but it's absolutely doable but you just
take the you rewrite the story and go
okay there's a couple never against here
yep there's a couple never again so i'm
not going to be put
in that position again to where
if i'm the victim of something else
it'll be something else it won't be that
again there you go because i'm not going
to set myself in i'm not going to walk
down that alley and get mugged again
that's right i walk down that alley i'm
going to go into that right the borrower
is slave to the lender i don't borrow
money that's right
i'm not going down that alley some of
that stuff is about trauma which i talk
about in the book some of it's about
grief what to talk about some of it is
as simple as we talked about earlier
i'm 40 years old and i don't know how to
make i got i don't have a classroom
where i just have insta friends anymore
how do you even do that anymore yeah we
talk about making friends and it almost
feels reductive but that's where we are
right here's here's how you go make
friends again so it covers a lot of
bases there
own your past change your future on
pre-sale now
at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jeff and christy
are in pennsylvania and says on my
screen you guys are debt-free
congratulations
thank you dave thank you well done how
much have you paid off
uh 245
880
all right how long did this take
three years and three months
all right good for you guys and your
range of income during that time
so we started out around 124
124 000 and we ended up at 180 000.
very good very good way to go what do
you guys do for a living
i am an rn and um jeff i am a carpenter
good good
what kind of debt was the 246 000
so the biggest portion of it was the
mortgage and then i had quite a bit of
student loans that was a huge part of it
um a little bit was a car we financed
and a very very small portion was a
credit card wow so you're kind of normal
yeah
how long you guys been married
uh
seven years jeff you got to have that
number right on top of your head brother
so
how much was the student loan again
um i think i originally was around 80
000 but we were already plugging away in
it so when we um when we really got
serious about paying down debt i think i
had it down to about 40 000. okay i'm
confused i missed something 246 thousand
yeah you paid off your mortgage yes we
paid off our money oh i missed that i
missed it too whoa okay there we go
all right and so how much of this was
mortgage
oh the majority the majority of it okay
so way to go guys you're weird people i
love it yeah very good what's the house
worth
oh we're probably worth about threes i
feel like yeah 300 the market's very
good so it's
worth a good amount right now so 300 000
and you guys are how old
i am 51 and i am 44. and you have a paid
for house
yeah it's awesome yeah and you two have
had a really boring last few years as a
carpenter and a nurse huh
yeah what happened never stop working
through the pandemic i can't even
imagine you two flying by each other in
the night good grief i'm so grateful for
both of you
man there was a lot of that at times
yeah yeah pretty much essential workers
yeah for sure
so what caused you three years and three
months ago to start this plan
i think we just decided well well part
of it was i was looking into like you
know let's get control of our debt with
controller finances i started to think
about retirement and i started to panic
a little bit about that
um and we ended up registering for your
financial peace university class
um went through the whole program and
that really sort of kick-started our our
our process to getting all of this paid
off cool at your church or online
we started with the church and then had
to switch to online okay all right wow
so game on three years and three months
house and everything is done mic drop
the theft
wow
wow absolutely fabulous
way to go guys how does it feel to not
have a payment in the world
you know it takes a while for it to soak
in
you know after you're done you're like
okay well nothing felt like it changed
you know you're still the same person
you go the same job do the same thing
it's just there is an element of stress
that's just not there and i get to keep
all my money
yeah yeah it's not going to some stupid
bank
and we were so close to getting paid off
and right towards the end our furnace
and our water heater broke of course it
did
it wasn't anything we could fix we had
to literally replace them but thanks to
the emergency fund we were able to pull
out the 9 500 it took to fix that and
still get out of debt wow
way to go
way to go you guys what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
uh it's really about discipline and
changing your habits and then of course
setting the goal and supporting each
other was huge i mean there was times we
were stressed and you know it took every
last penny to get through the month but
we just supported each other because we
had the same vision
that's a big deal yeah it is
yeah and um were you guys handling money
together before you started this
sort of yeah yeah yeah
that's the least convincing answer oh
yeah
maybe not we are now we definitely work
at everything as a team now
now it's got now it's got some clothes
on it yeah that's good
way to go you guys way to go well done
did you have cheerleaders outside the
two of you
yeah we have some friends that are a
very uh supportive that was helpful um
and they actually recently paid their
mortgage off too so hey
anybody tell you you were crazy
um yeah i would say but you know we
really kind of kept it kept it under our
hat because
people just get funny about it you know
when
family can be funny and friends can be
funny when it comes down to money so not
like funny ha ha
like funny go home you're like crazy
funny you're crazy yeah i like it well
done y'all well done well we've got a
copy of the baby steps millionaires
number one bestseller for you guys
because that's the next chapter in your
story for sure what's your uh investment
accounts amount to right now
uh that's an area we need to work on um
i know my 401 is just under 100 yeah and
and i think i'm around like 1 1 30 150
somewhere around there we got a ways to
go with that okay well you're worth a
half million dollars already
yeah
yeah with the house yeah that's what i
mean house part of it that's an asset
yeah well done
and uh you know so you know you're going
to be baby steps millionaires in no time
so we'll send you a copy of the book you
finish this journey now and play all the
way through the well done very very well
done and a copy of total money makeover
too for you to give away to somebody
who's just getting started and it'll
show them exactly what to do step by
step how to work these baby steps how to
work that debt snowball all the stuff
you guys have done and you can hand it
to a friend and encourage them that'll
be great okay good stuff well done jeff
and christy bethlehem pennsylvania 246
thousand dollars paid off in three years
and three months making 124 to 180 house
and everything they're weird people
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
where is that free
[Music]
[Applause]
they don't even need to count
that's how it's done
that is how it's done right there
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five mike is in
anchorage alaska mike what's up
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
um so i just wanted to bounce something
off you real quick and see what my
family should do next so i'm currently
in the military and i'm
our annual income is 1 30 is our take
home
um we plan on renting for the next nine
years and my question is
i'm going to be maxing my 401k this year
we also are maxing of ira roth ira for
my wife
should we and i just found out we
can
max our 2021
roth iras
up until
the tax deadline up until you file
file or tax deadline whichever is first
yeah
correct so we have forty thousand
dollars
in our bank account should we double max
two iras and then continue to do
that moving forward yep yep yep is it
ever possible to over invest in
retirement
um you're probably not going to get
there
but yeah you could have so much there
that you i mean let's say you were 30
years old you had two million dollars in
retirement you probably need to have
some outside retirement starting so that
you can access some money before 59 and
a half but um
very few people actually hit that and
hit that position
you might hit it
if you look up you got millions of
millions in retirement and you still got
a ways before you can be 59 and a half
then yeah you may want to slow down and
reach over and do what we call bridge
investing to get ready for that make up
for that difference there but yeah
you're right on track i would keep doing
what you're doing the other thing you
need to think about doing since you're
running the military route by the way
thank you for your service
is um you may want to think about having
some side investing right now
and if that is if that slows down your
retirement a little bit that's okay to
get ready to buy a house
let's have a house fund where you're
putting money in mutual funds to where
10 years from today write a check for
that house when you do buy after you
come out of the military this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 62 8
trust in him at all times pour out your
heart to him for he
is our refuge
charles swindoll said we are all faced
with a series of great opportunities
brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations i love that
quote that is a great quote
fun fun fun fun charles is a quote
machine
to say the least
and uh
so we're going to do a theme hour here
in a few weeks dr john deloney and i and
it will be on mental health
on boundaries on relationships on
wellness on
anything that falls in that category
where you can
ask him dr john deloney questions
specifically during that hour
and if you want to participate in that
uh what do we send them to ramsey
solutions.com ask and just put mental
health in the subject line there it is
okay anything that's going on marriage
anything you just take those calls on my
show and we'd love to do some of that
here yeah if you'll ever listen to dr
john dolone show these are going to be
called similar to that or um a little
less serious
[Music]
[Laughter]
but uh yeah so it's ramsey solutions.com
ask if you want to participate in that
if you have a question for dr d and me
i'll be happy to put that into that
mental health theme it sounds like a
children's book dave dr d and me
i'll co-write it with you
yeah it's i i'm thinking somewhere
there's some children already
traumatized by just the idea you would
not sell a lot of copies yeah so but
yeah check it out uh
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com they have a
100 satisfaction guarantee that means
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your window
blinds for free free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
all the time you're going to save even
more always use ramsey as your promo
code it's magic it'll save you money all
right today's question comes from
devonte in chicago devante asks i'm a
recent college grad with 50 grand in
mostly student loan debt i'm 25 and work
two jobs one as a delivery driver at 16
bucks an hour and another with a local
news program at 14 an hour i'm looking
to grow professionally as a videographer
my skills are in media tv productions
and marketing i've heard many success
stories where people have grown their
video videography businesses and are
making over six figures a year what's
your best advice on how to clear debt
and grow my savings so i can support
myself as an entrepreneur
this is like an underhand pitch to you
dave what'd you tell this guy
well um i mean we're going to work you
on the personal side through the baby
steps that's right where you work your
way through the debt using the debt
snowball and those kinds of things
i don't think we're going to be able to
stop you as an entrepreneur i think he's
already rocking he's hustling grinding
he's got his eye on the prize he knows
where he's going
what i what i would tell you is this um
as a young entrepreneur what i didn't
realize was i didn't know what i didn't
know and the best way to solve that is
in business what we call is best
practices
and that means find someone maybe in
another city
that is who you want to be
they're doing videography they're making
200 000 a year
and they're in these
you know the types of things they're
videoing or the kind of things you want
to video they're doing the types of
business you want to be in and make it
the kind of money you want to make and
i'll call them and just go hey i'm a
young guy and i'm just getting started i
want to be you when i grow up could i
come over and spend the day with you and
just shadow you and ask you questions
while i'm looking over your shoulder all
day long and and then ask them okay
what's the dumbest thing you ever did
what's the smartest thing what do you
wish you'd done well if you were me what
would you do um and how do you make this
money and how do you do your billing and
where do you get your customers and um
how do you do your uh
pricing structure and uh
i don't think actually taking the videos
actually using the camera is gonna be
your issue it's the running of the
business it's gonna be your issue so you
jump in and get uh best practices from
somebody like that or two or three like
that um and that's gonna be better than
taking a college course on running a
business
because those guys are and gals are out
there actually doing it
it's not theory and you're going to
mimic what they do and i do that to this
day i do too if i find someone that's in
a in a space that we're in uh that's
doing better than we're doing
um i always want to go spend a little
time with them or send one of my guys
gals around here to spend some time with
them and go okay how are you doing that
what are you doing with this and how we
doing this and um you know some of the
other people in talk radio and i have
shared ideas back and forth shapiro that
gang ben shapiro glenn beck those
organizations and our organization
interact all the time and help each
other and okay how do you do this when
you're doing a live event what are you
doing
when you're getting your podcast
promoted how you doing it and you know
we're just asking questions all the time
uh from people that are
you know even if it's a nuanced corner
of the business and they're doing better
than we're doing maybe we're doing
better overall maybe but this little
area over here they're they're just
going to zoom zoom yeah and i want to
know how they're doing that and copy it
emulate it yeah you know that's uh
that's that's the best way for you to
get going i remember i i was in grad
school and uh an actual therapist came
in to met with us
just to answer questions and i i just
cut through the chase a lot of the
questions were
kumbaya questions and i just said hey
in this small town how do you make six
figures being a counselor and he said
to this room he said you're not gonna
like my answer i said all right go for
it and he said
work really hard and be really really
good at what you do
and i remember thinking well that's a
deflating answer and also that's the
best answer i could have ever heard
because i'll outwork you and i'll do
what it takes to get really good at it
right yeah work really hard and be real
good at what you do man money takes care
of itself
yeah you know when we're training
financial coaches and and
the old days the first time we did a
room full of people were training him
and and a guy raises his hand he goes
okay
you're
coaching broke people
how do you get paid
and our answer is always up front yeah
because you're not going to get paid if
you don't get paid up front uh you're
either going to donate your services or
you're going to get paid up front
because you can't you know broke people
aren't they're they're there because
they can't pay bills right they're there
and so you've got to you've got to walk
with them and it's kind of a joke line
but it's a best practice yeah you know
it's the real thing it's
an actual
business issue um and how do you get
them to keep an appointment once they
set an appointment you know and uh very
skin in the game yeah yeah very
interesting process
lisa's in washington d.c hi lisa welcome
to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
can you hear me okay absolutely what's
up
fantastic um first i want to start by
saying that i know that all of what i'm
experiencing is ordained
i get that
but i feel completely lost i am the
primary manager of my mother's
financial matters
she's 91 years old and lives in her home
which is paid in full she owns a
commercial property that is also paid in
full
the house is willed to me
the commercial property is will to my
sister
together and separately we've reached
out to investors about selling the
building
but it's too small so they're not
interested so because of where it's
situated they can't build up or around
it so
now we're looking at her house
her expenses
the you know the care expenses have
exceeded her income which is about 5 000
a month
so she's not suffering too badly so we
do have a care you know character that
comes in monday friday but now she's for
help for her we're thinking about you
talk to a commercial real estate agent
about selling the commercial building or
just for talk to investors
we spoke with close
and no commercial real estate agent
thinks they can sell that building
they could sell it but for what we would
get after the capital gains tax is hit
it will be worth it
and what would it sell for what's that
income
400.
why is that not worth it
well after the capital gains
taxes aren't 15
did i mention that these facilities are
12 to 14 000 a
month i mean this is the washington dc
area and it's ridiculous no i'm sorry
i'm sorry the the you you have it rented
for 14 000 a month
oh no no no the the to the cost to put
her in
assisted living facility is about 12 to
14 000
a month so that's what we would be
paying
but this is a current source of income
for her so right now we're using that to
pay the
you know the woman what's it what's it
creating an income
3 000. yeah i'm selling it and paying
the capital gains tax she's 92.
and by the way 12 14 000 a month is uh
keep her at home
and keep paying for in-home care it's
cheaper it's a better quality of life
you can do a lot cheaper than fifteen
thousand dollars a month
and you can hire 24-hour staff cheaper
now
and i would
i saw the commercial building
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
into the reference christ jesus just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you